hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to a brand new amnesia
custom story called weird dreams and I'm
already concerned because dreams should
not be possessive there unless dream is
whatever it's fine no big deal this is a
highly rated amnesia custom story and
8.9 which is a rare fine these days I
mean usually the exceptional ones are
like 9.5 and most so this one's got to
be pretty good alright you can't you
have to see the difference between a
dream and a nightmare by x3w oh you know
I realized it actually has been a while
since I sat down and did an actual you
know not custom custom M needs a custom
story but just um one that embraces okay
it is bedtime this was a long day and
like like most a me as your husband
story's gonna start off with someone
going to sleep but this one definitely
because of weird dreams it has been a
while since I sat down and did a regular
I need to custom story then embrace the
original amnesia the Dark Descent you
know castle not trying to be something
creative which I don't mind I mean I'm
not saying that's a bad thing but it's
just been a while since I got into it
like that there we go okay beware
standing in darkness is bad okay because
I really I really like amnesia I really
do it's one of the best experiences in
the game you can probably find it's just
perfect in a lot of ways I mean
everything has its flaws but just about
the closest you can come to perfect in
an atmospheric or survival horror game
okay so starting off something any
behind the paintings no all right god it
has been a while
probably over a month geez oh the
gramophone any clues here nope uh-uh
hello just a strange dagger night dagger
huh
oh good you awake you wake yeah no this
is not a dream it is a nightmare and to
wake up is not as easy as you think in
this nightmare you can die and all your
feelings are totally real to escape this
horror you need to find a night orb the
only one I can do is help you to survive
this adventure take the night dagger in
front of you and use him to destroy the
night or but okay it seemed to have a
strange obsession with night bra maybe
you want to get rid of that so I like oh
and yes for everyone that's been asking
me of course I'm going to play amnesia
omen a machine for pigs I mean why
wouldn't I I'm such a huge fan of
amnesia hello I see something there oh
wait system tinderbox huh
I thought those some special never mind
my keen eyes spidey-sense was tingling a
nice side okay hello see so far really
well lit in this play ah hey or the dead
body come from how strange
um oh there we go finally found the
lantern anything Annie's gonna fall out
maybe fluke loop loop loop chair get out
of there
aha sanity potion you know I get a lot
of these and other amnesia custom
stories and I end up never using them my
mind is like a rock or I run away
screaming before it can affect me either
one you know one of the other okay so
that's that I found a key that's right
key to the corridor I'm guessing this
corridor quickly alright go
ah where which direction what's the
urgent oh he's not here
oh okay oh all right okay
crowbar huh huh yeah yep the whipping
come on
ah really come on ah geez
Doug is that back way what's down here
hang on one sec all I know where that
thing is I just I just realized I broke
the the boards off the door where ice
not where I heard the sounds of the
monster coming from out probably mistake
oh no boon ah-ha I see some behind those
bones turn the box please do not ask me
something about this you would not
understand but what I am talking about
you cannot answer me anyway
screw you then I'll help them me huh huh
loud down a dumb let's see move forward
ah statute hate statues ah switchy
switch what does this do
clunk oh hi whoa
you startled me okay so anything over
here
jump-scare maybe yeah a lot of runs
outside of where I got the crowbar from
what is whoa hmm I don't like this place
oh there's nothing in this chest well
what a waste oh wait there's a nut [ __ ]
yeah there we go key to something secret
key a secret key to a secret place did I
find a secret
you are the Blitz oh man I must have
found an easter egg or something it
wasn't exactly a hard Easter egg to find
I hang on
where am i using this this door huh
yeah no ah balls nice door no
well well I don't know we're seeing that
painting before yeah let me try the door
is over here maybe there's a door in
here I'm not sure I got a key but that's
only half of it I can't get the Easter
Egg unless I actually find something
from it who was your son back
ha ha ha ha ha ha my genius is that it
is it the only thing I'm like so Pro ed
Anita
Sian real so Stickley help ok
I'm Chisholm huh yep nope ok so the
secret door must be further up ahead
just make it one last check yeah nothing
here alright alright then I found a key
and I'm the Blitz I are the Blitz ah me
oh this wasn't locked in the beginning
huh picked up needle yup the turtle oh
[ __ ] I wasn't even looking at it
Jesus ah don't your ear lilies so naked
uh man I hope enough oisin for pigs just
for my sake I'd you guys whose sake that
everything isn't so very naked cuz
everything's naked why why is everything
naked it's really damn dark down here
ok ok wait hang on secret door nope ok
secret door okay not like the prison
Lowell in here my god I hated the prison
level in the mansion in the original
yeah in a lot of ways I want to go back
and play you know the originally I need
you again not you know by myself not
doing like an extra commentary or
something but you know just playing it
for me because when I first played it
you know I played it for you guys and I
don't mind doing that but I wouldn't
mind just letting myself get purified on
my own because in a lot of ways it kind
of helped me alleviate a lot of fear if
you know I am I know that I'm doing this
for the entertainment of others and you
guys are watching me so it's kind of
pressure to be good ah got it first try
on the best so I would like to just
experience it all like I would not be
doing nearly as well as I am right now
in terms of fear puzzle up oh oh he's
coming hey cometh ah
Oh boxes there can't see me I'm facing
the wall you can't see me this is a bad
hiding place this is a bad hiding place
ain't nothing
don't come here oh come here
ah good all right huh I gotta get past
him to the water over there I think
if I toss a box there you heard that but
don't look in this corner just guy
staring at the myth wall if I walked
into a room even if I was answering I
saw some guy just staring at a corner in
the wall I would not be that guy
mostly because that's usually how horror
stories started I'm gone
I shouldn't be sprinting don't go far oh
my god
no it's bad ah [ __ ] good day's us stop
with a double carrot no huh I'm not good
was this this the secret door haha what
that seemed like the progression door
why did the three great door key unlock
that as I are the Blitz be careful you
being haunted Brown okay alright good a
good news by the water monster I'm
guessing
hey stop it by that at least use a
different screaming name this one jump
scares McGillicuddy Oh what uh-huh yeah
okay sorry I did not try to grab that
guy's crotch there I don't know why my
hand showed up I was falling and I just
I was trying to brace myself and he just
went right on the cross I'm tough what
happened my I turned around there was a
statue and I got concerned and then I
fell over I'm not that big of a baby how
am I
all right hello what what well what was
the point of knocking me out why didn't
I die there seems like I should have
died I'm being hunted by statue I think
which is like my worst nightmare I'm
gonna crush your head but where ah come
on come on there we go oh yeah you get
get some food yeah okay I guess I got a
head back like was this just the secret
area I think up yeah there we go there
we go
I probably should be using my
tinderboxes all night but I got so much
oh no I don't ever mind I thought I did
hi buddy you're still alive ain't you
ah nothing I can do about you sorry
moving on is what is distorting my
vision right oh no it's just the way the
textures were I thought that was
distorting my vision for a second there
I moved forward seriously guys I really
really
I just love the field again jump-scare
potato jump-scare whatever alright
I did not put my I did not put that on
my wine you take it away from me
why'd you take my lantern away from it
what are you gonna do to me are you good
ah ah you know I get away get away get
away guys [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you I
feel another Cooper oh I've said it
before it else here good I really like
amnesia I'm really looking forward to
using machines to think not just because
more of the original game which is like
oh god probably gonna be a masterpiece
but giving people more tools to work
with for making custom stories because
the tool set and you know everything
that was available losses I can't go for
that everything that was available for
people to use in custom stories is
actually not that much it needs our
Justine added about as much content that
they could use as the other one okay
and amnesia a machine for pig will just
allow people to get a lot more creative
with things cuz you know man instead of
relying on making a whole new material
in complete conversion mods and
definitely ways to well what am i doing
I was like locked up supposed to do here
kinda wedgies
I mean does this guy have something on
him need I mean I just I can't wait to
see what people ah okay I don't know
what the deal was I mean what was the
point of going back there that door was
locked on a don't have a key
I didn't get a key there wasn't another
door over here was there I was the only
door right thankfully now I can't even
go back huh uh-oh
markiplier be stuck again
whoa don't hit it maybe I was supposed
to get a key like back here water and
sanitation in the water key in the water
no like it
I hate water I hate hate hate you are
there had to be something in a splash
sounds like one of us has to be
something in one of these that I must
have overlooked aha see AHA I knew it I
know it I knew I overlooked something
rusty Keith got it okay I knew there had
to be something I I've learned more
though if I use my brain and stop
panicking for two seconds I could figure
things out carry on
hit this over with I don't know what's
in this red misty room but I'm not happy
about it
hello hi Marga my hair go on no no no no
no no no no no Pro dubbing dude Oh who's
this ha ha oh this is Teddy
girls Duggar there don't judge me I know
he wants you to come to me shut up shut
up uh I hate the water monsters they're
just the worst in every way everything
about him is horrible y'all got in the
fire water monsters in amnesia white
knight guy I can't believe I put off
that a major cut some story for so long
because that was really a fantastic one
I mean you know there was a lot of
things I could critique and some people
say that I'm over critical like in my
last I in stock people said I was over
critical but I was like we gave it a 9
out of 10 for an indie game that's
amazing for me
you know I people think that if it's not
10 out of 10 it's not good but that's
not true because a Hello Baby I'll see
you out there I'm coming for you no not
like that not like I'm coming for you
no um more for like I'm all coming to
rescue you yeah but seriously if I'm if
I you know if I'm critical about
anything you know just always remember
that I can't do anything for myself
no game making skills you know all I do
is play games and the hell is that an
arrow shaft what is that poking through
the other side
what does oh it's a tree oh okay so
there's the outside it's just little
texture poking through okay so I can't
get through there I don't see a key in
here do i no I do not we just light
these candles so I don't go waste oil in
here oh that helps
oh yeah that's great I wish it was more
easy to know which which ones are
useless to light I mean that way I waste
a lot of tinderboxes lighting useless
ones just Brickley try to get Eddie to
delay this is not a useless one that is
a good one
nevermind that is a suck one damn it
all of these it just must be the extra
dark because there are dark levels and
then amnesia has extra dark levels
there's got to be a key that I'm missing
here somewhere here maybe and if I was
worse you know if I was a terrible
player but I'd be having trouble with
this ha ha ha oh ha ha ha ha oh ok shut
up everything up here anything up here
no really
Oh what am i doing I don't know where to
go I I got got nothing here
see I'm absolutely sure that there's
nothing here there's a shovel don't use
a shovel for it's nothing here huh
sometimes you can see a glow better in
the dark
look if an object alone see anything
it's nothing underneath those big
barrels maybe find these barrels no no
no no no no blow no glow no glow what do
what am i doing I'm uh I don't have
anything I have just a knife I need to
use the knife from the door and what's
with these oh oh oh I'm coming for you
baby I'm coming to get you I like that
bit oh hello what hello baby how you
doing
I know I've been away for so long but
I'm here again you look so good in the
light of the moon
mmm your curves are curvy I don't know
symmetrical flirty especially within
that on the object now real people like
you have to okay yeah enough silliness
I always get freaked out one of her
chair just like kind of kind of lets
just hanging around in the middle of a
rumor facing me when I walk into
something really that's it oh I guess it
is just a small house mm-hmm huh I think
of that fireplace no I don't have any
tinderboxes I don't know really tender
boxes
anything else under the bed I know that
oil was under the bed but else
Herbert no not that look to it
okay back out we go weird dreams are
made of these Who am I to disagree
battle at 7c okay
I've already established that I am NOT a
good singer okay this is where I could
have come out the door but I didn't did
I go in this house rude
no I wanted that house okay so let's try
this one right listen and then we'll try
the other one and then we'll go flirt
with a statue some more because I'm
apparently crazy and then we'll go on
our way
did you know I can make it right yeah I
would prove myself a bit more of a big
whiny bubble blowing baby every time I
played it
ha
ah come on I'm so brave you don't get me
I'm too brave I'm so brave I loop past
braveness Max and then correct I get
scaredy baby don't care no out of the
weird house no not not to question you
whoa hello what uh what uh what what ha
what happened your as explored what the
hell hey what you get on me
ah Tolly my ID ok so there's an exact
duplicate on the ceiling oh no no ok
good I get oil I got a good idea I'm
this wasting oil being here cuz ami who
there was nothing for me I could have
just carried on but I have a pension for
checking everything bad had it hello
baby how are you doing I'm sorry I got
to move on but hopefully I'll see you
again later tonight ok um ok only one
way to go I hope I really hope there
wasn't a key that I was put to grab
because I did not see anything okay I
mean I was pretty thorough
don't you agree I was pretty thorough on
that way what is this hello whoa what up
whoa too much shake away too much shake
there buddy
ha ha oh yeah that one's a little
excessive on the camera shake so ah you
gotta be kidding me oh no my sanity oops
how you excellently used to loud down at
dump Oh Oh God okay ha oh it's locked
not dying our Hawaii balls I gotta find
a key then oh come on I swear I looked
all over for a key there was no key how
ah stop it wasn't okay
darah from the heart from hell's heart i
pierce the I forget the quote uh okay
come on come on come on where is it
where are you
uh oh oh whoa oh oh I swear I checked
all of those houses there was no key no
one okay I'm game I'm breaking the game
I should not break the game I will not I
won't do it oh man I checked every oh
hell oh wait this putt start whining
like a even bigger baby than are already
a man here's a path to another house oh
ye oh hello uh nope hmm how suspicious
question are you scared
if I would cotched in this dream i would
i'm not catch stood I'm not quite
catched it yet well I was scary yeah
that's more scary than that ones okay
yeah here
Christ Karamu the scary pot fallin try
to give me a murderer
Oh and that symbol get there that's
probably not a good time Romain's a you
statue our full zest all right more
symbols on the ground I guess I got a
stack up to get to this up one stack BAM
like a boss haha doll it takes what
where am I going and like booshed it
boost me over ha keep coming Oh box
ception oh ok yes
super mega hyper key
there's only legend said that existence
it can't possibly be real
why did I just think of bragging ballsy
right then the legendary Super Saiyan
can't drift it's not real something Oh
got it funny beat them haunted fun okay
so carrying on we got a key now oh hello
baby ba oh I don't have to take time God
move on I gotta move forward baby no
time for idle chitchat over here I'm
doing pretty good actually I mean
surprisingly compared to my other
playthroughs of amnesia and whatnot I'm
doing pretty good
I mean I'm haven't gotten stuck yet I'm
doing good and if you haven't noticed
I'm doing this in all in one playthrough
cuz I feel like you know I saw that this
wasn't exactly oh come on there we go
I thought that this wasn't terribly long
so I figured you know I'll give you guys
a treat and just do it all in one that
way you guys don't have to wait around
for Oh what was that what was that just
a monster look at this particularly good
bad hiding but I don't know not bad
hiding
let's go dining look of it there yeah
you heard that who's up there who you
buddy man this ain't rolls with me
there's all amnesia custom stories one
big troll fest come on bring it around
[ __ ] yo you're not the only daughter
maybe was trying to tell me something
that was bad hiding maybe it was like I
shouldn't be here
because it's gonna come right back here
pretty go where'd he go
pretty go where to go pretty good I
really hate the MU the dusty monster the
Justin monsters really bad yeah I don't
know what it is about it but he'll just
the sounds he makes music oh god to
chase music the the Haunted sheep in the
background go - okay you go that bat
right there you hear that longitude
monster sneaking sneak like a bat Oh
what's this epic whatever hammer why do
we need a hammer is that all that was in
there why do I need a hammer man I'm not
doing too well good thing I got all
these sanity potions bad hiding my left
butt cheek I was a great hiding place
I'm so pro at amnesia
okay is there anything up here than I
need hang on up there we go uh-uh no
okay I just got a hammer and I know what
I'm gonna do with it oh that might be it
wait didn't that oh I get it
oh yeah I fell in the hole I forgot I
forgot that I fell in a hole I thought
that was way back out my bad
I'm an idiot ah oh no this is about
weight I'm gonna stab de pecheur aiyo
come here orb don't get to UM you know
you're sitting there all helplessly like
who's pretty I almost stabbed the piss
out of you wha just touch on nice with
you ah I am hot
good work okay let me guess I Unleashed
some diabolical evil seems like
good work now the nightmare can come
alive it was trapped in the dream what
would that I should stop reading this
creepy books oh that was here
oh no diabolical anything weird dreams '
should not be there not and this is how
a nightmare ends okay anyway that was
really really well done I mean beside
the trolley thing I was kind of funny at
times tonic the piss out of the
atmosphere was trying to create that's
okay you know that was a really good
every good story I mean it had quite a
few jump scares not too many though not
like some but you know that was all fine
an ad good work with the mannequins that
I always hate died doesn't mean a kid so
much so anyway that was without an
example of a really well-made custom
story I mean the reason it doesn't get
like above an eight point nine eight
point nine there's a really solid score
like you guys should not get this cuz
it's not like an A in terms of homework
scores but you know what really sets
that this apart from those other ones
like the things in the night aggressor
phobia and white knight is that those go
the extra mile to put some you know
something special to it this would be a
very good example what you could do with
with a amnesia custom story and the
amnesia based set of tools but those are
the ones they get that extra five points
point five points just because they like
custom textures special story more
better storytelling one on in like that
but that doesn't mean that this one is
bad I'm not being harsh I'm just saying
why so anyway that was a very good
custom story I hope you all enjoyed it
so thank you so much for watching click
the annotation for more custom stories
that I've done and as always I will see
you in the next video bye-bye
and the layout is Houston parable
forever designed it is pulled apart from
go nowhere oh [ __ ]
Oh God